well let's round this out but i can't i
can't uh
i can't end it with
without uh a few thoughts on
just this idea of the spirited man like
where does it come from and what does it
mean
to you personally
okay so where it comes from is this book
by matthew b
crawford and it's called shop class as
soul craft
and matthew b crawford is a writer
and he started out he had a phd from i
can't remember i think maybe university
of chicago
uh in philosophy and he worked at think
tanks
uh made made a lot of money consulting
like i think big like corporations and
executives
but his real love was working on vintage
motorcycles
and he was like he raced his volkswagen
beetle when he was a kid
and he wrote this book called shop
classes soul club craft
and it's about the kind of like
intellectual significance
of working with one's hands of making
things
with one's hands and um
i read it i think i read it in two i
think it came out in 2009 i might have
read it in 2011 or something like that
and it was an incredible relief to know
that there were people out there that
were like
bookworms and they were tinkerer people
like me
who like to mess around with machines
and stuff and this was it and this is
like the book about it
and in it he has a chapter where he's
talking about
um how the new cars you just
you need millions of dollars worth of
diagnostic equipment to figure out
what's wrong with them and you plug in a
usb into your 7-series bmw
and all this stuff comes out and he said
something like
the spirited man needs to know
exactly what's wrong with his car or
something like that or like the you know
and then he went on to talk about
basically that the spirited man is a man
who can
take care of his own stuff and so that's
to me what it is is a
you know the spirited man is the man who
i said it in the
in one of the episodes is a man who
takes care of his own business
so that's what it is it's also it's this
discomfort or
intolerance for asymmetry in the
universe right when there's something
off like you walked into our studio and
immediately gravitated towards this
corner where we have a bunch of stuff
stacked and you're like that is
unacceptable
right yeah it's not it's very expensive
stuff
it's not it's not like uh i'm sure a lot
of people would call it like an ocd it's
more like a hyper vigilance and a
sensitivity to
this idea that that there's a right way
of doing things
yeah you know what i mean like yeah it's
not okay to be
to slack off on that like there is there
is valor
in doing things properly you know we
live in this very
in this era this this era have you read
the fourth turning do you know that book
no but i saw your book report good
it's so good yeah because these guys are
financial guys and you can trust these
guys
i know it sounds weird these financial
guys they make these predictions they
say okay these trends exist
and then they make money off of it which
is the hardest thing to do
so in my mind you can listen to these
guys these guys these
these words have weight like ray dalio
yeah he can predict the future he's good
at it he's been doing it for 50 years
so one of the things that this guy says
is people in our generation gen
x and we also line up with the lost
generation
that's the same generation in that
history slot hemingway and all those
guys
they were exers of their time we grew up
in a time
a post-war very rich unraveling time
where kind of anything went
right and one of the conclusions that i
drew
with anything goes is no that's not true
anything goes provided certain things
are perfect
and i don't know this i
to me my whole being able to wrestle
my craziness into something productive
was all because of me learning all
disciplines you know learning techniques
and learning
things that aren't negotiable you know
you sometimes as a
as a creative person you think oh i can
re blah blah blah
i don't need the three act structure i
don't need plot
i don't know no no no no what thousands
of years
of of of innovation and you're not and
you're an exception to
thousands of years of plato and socrates
and all these people
being you know having to follow these
rules but you don't no no no no no
and i think i don't know maybe this is
these are
sort of the little these are the little
things that are
just the residue of me learning that
stuff the absolute hard way
yeah but how does that how does that
square with the fourth turning in the
sense that
you know you're perceiving yourself as
as a cog in
in a machine that's kind of you know
progressing towards this
you know this this dismantling as we as
we progress towards
2028 right like we're in this age of
basically you know an unraveling of
sorts right a destruction
a reckoning crisis we're in the crisis
unraveling is what we grew up in we grew
up in the unraveling was
1960 okay the
okay no 1980 to 1984
maybe 1988 end of reagan to
2008 that was the unraveling now we're
in the crisis
but before the unraveling is the
awakening and that's the
six starts in 63 with the assassination
of
but our one of the characteristics of
our generation throughout history you
can go back to civil world
is that we are a repair generation and
we are the ones that say no no no no no
you have to save this you have to save
these institutions
this is of value and that
you know and and reading reading that
book
and reading the other one the the
spirited man the you know matthew b
crawford book
shop classes soulcraft and frankly
listening to
certain jordan peterson lectures
it made me very comfortable with the
fact of like
it would be artistically
rewarding and valuable to isolate to to
like really
narrowly focus on your
like propensity to like repair in a very
literal sense
and if you are literal and precise
enough about it
then it will have a universal it'll have
a universal resonance with people
and so i try not to be self-conscious or
perceptive
like that's all subconscious stuff that
i learned
after i've made the thing i try to just
really dial in like
you know these little details i just try
to really dial into them and then just
trust that in writing the
this you know the words that i'm going
to narrate
that it will have some kind of universe
there'll be some universal power in it
but the thing i'm trying to i think the
thing that i'm consciously trying to
to talk about is that there
there there are things that we have to
preserve and there are very valuable
things and
many great people gave lives and stuff
to
bring us this thing that we this
civilization that we live in and it's
unbelievably great it's unbelievably
good and look i hate it just as much as
everybody else
and i [ __ ] about it and i hate that my
[ __ ]
airpod pros do not sync up
every time it's like you are a trillion
dollar company solve that problem please
how about when you publish a podcast and
it doesn't show up
in the [ __ ] app for like 40 hours
yeah that's unacceptable that's
hospitalization for me yeah
yeah well it speaks to you
you know reading that and seeing that
must have been like i've never felt so
hurt in my life like now i can fulfill
my destiny
as a repair man and preach and speak to
this idea of preservation and
and appreciation for the tactile and the
analog
because these things do have meaning
especially as we hurtle towards
this disposable culture where
everything gets thrown away i mean and
it's it's almost not
like responsibility doesn't always fall
on
the individual's shoulders like my
daughter has a record player and she
said to me the other day like
can we go get this fixed it's broken how
old is she 13.
okay and and i said yeah of course i
said why don't you i want you to go
online i want you to find a place that
will repair it and then call me
right yeah yeah so so
so the reply is guitar center i know
guitar center
is not going to repair a record player
and i said i want you to call guitar
center and ask him that question
figure out like we did find a place in
woodland hills that does audio repair
wonderful so we're going to go have this
experience right
so we take this record player that's
probably worth
65 it's not a high-end thing it's a it's
a
you know it's a it's intended to be
disposable
right but we're going to try to repair
it the repair shop
requires 50 just to look at it before
the and then 10 days before they
actually give you a diagnosis and tell
you whether they can even fix it and
what that
what's that what that is going to look
like so we're in the waiting phase now
but my prognosis is that they're either
not going to be able to fix it or
the cost of fixing it is going to so
exceed
the value of the thing itself that it
doesn't make economics
so you think to do it so you think what
the cost of fixing it will exceed the
value of the thing itself
that's where i think i mean that's where
i mean
that i wrestle with that is that's
basically like my life
is wrestling with that and the truck my
truck is the embodiment of that
right but your truck is if you want to
be rational about it you're right and if
you want to be rational about it throw
that thing in the garbage
can and go get an iphone but this is an
irrational thing that you're doing
it's irrational to do that record player
that's not rational that's what i'm
that's what
that that makes my point that it isn't
the individual's fault
for not adopting a sensibility like
yours right because you have to you have
to know that you're irrational
to it not at all no this is it's a gift
it's a gift i have a gift i've been like
this always since i was a little baby
i've been like this it's a gift
and i'm grateful for it um
and i don't know i don't know what to
say i don't know what to say beyond that
but i've exploited it and it's
yeah it's i don't think you're
exploiting it you're expressing it
okay you're doing and you're doing it
beautifully um
and i think that's probably a good place
to to end it
[Music]
you